data types there are seven data types in
Java Script and we are going to go over
all them a boolean is just true or false
Francis if we have our data equals true
if data console.log boolean rule else
millions are lame and if we run that
boolean's rule but if we change that
data to false and we run that boolean's
are lame now we're down to null null is
an assignment value that means no value
null just means no value for instance if
we have bar N equals null and we try to
do some math with it console that log
and now since whenever you're doing math
with something that's equal to null
that's just going to be the same as 0 so
if we run that as you can see over in
the console on the side there it equals
0 now undefined is kind of similar to
null but not completely the same it
means a variable has not been declared
or it has been declared but it has not
yet been assigned a value for instance
let's scroll down a little bit if we
have VAR a and I'm not going to say that
this very little equals anything is just
VAR a now I'm going to console log a
plus 2
this is going to be a little different
than the null if we run that it's going
to see you see the letters in a in in
the console log that means not a number
if it's undefined it's not nothing it's
not zero like knowledge but it just
means not enough it's nothing it's not
it's not nothing it's not a number so
you can't actually add or do math with
something that's undefined now let's go
to the next one number this is pretty
self-explanatory just any numbers like
you can put there num equals 3.6 of
Arbour equals 6.4 and then if we try to
add these together I'm going to run that
and you can see at the very bottom of
the console you see the number ten
because three plates six plus six point
four is ten now we'll go to the next one
string o it gives an example they're
like how do you anything that's a word
so if we do var name equals both my name
and then we can do console dot log hi my
name is and with strings you can add
together so I can put plus name and if I
run that you can see in the bottom of
the console hi my name is Bo
now symbols are something that's new and
es6 this is a data type whose instance
whose instances are unique and immutable
so one thing different with strings if
you have two strings that equal the same
word they're the same we're like Bo and
Bo and if you check if they're equal it
will say that they're equal symbols are
a little different
let me give you an example so if we have
one symbol and we're going to equals
phoo and I'm actually just going to copy
this and put another one but we're going
to call this symbol 2 now if we do
console.log sim 1 equal equal equal sim
2 and if we see if they're equal let me
just clear the log here and run that you
can see at the very bottom it says false
they're not equal however if we change
one thing if we do if we convert this to
a string first if we run that we're
going to get an error so what did I do
wrong I need one more in parenthesis
okay so you can see it says false at
first and then true and just so you can
see what happens when you convert these
to a string you can see at the very
bottom now when you convert a symbol to
a string it says the word symbol and
then says what you call the symbol when
you're creating a symbol foo now the
last thing we're going to talk about our
objects an object is just a collection
of properties and the property is an
association between a name or a key and
a value let me give you an example we're
going to create a new object called my
car
and we're going to assign something
we're going to create the make to be
forward and when I put my car down model
which is going to equal Mustang if we
just do console dot log my car dot make
it's going to take this property from
from it's going to give us the value so
let's try that and as you can see it
shows Ford in the console because that's
what the make is the Ford thanks for
watching my name is beau Carnes don't
forget to subscribe and remember use
your code for good